Asalamu allayikum.
Good day Dr. Zakir. My name is Abdul
Hafi from Nigeria. I'm a student. Today
Muslims and non-Muslims all follow what
is known as constitution
and we all know that constitution is a
book written by human beings
Muslims non-Muslims alike indicating
that the constitution is not from Allah
the almighty and all countries rule and
judge people with the constitution and
they say it is the supreme law of the
land instead of Sharia
and that any law against the
constitution is null and wide including
Sharia and Allah subhanaa tala says in
the Quran in surah al maida chapter 5
verse 45 and whosoever does not judge by
that which Allah has revealed such
aimoon such a wrongdoers so I would like
to hear Dr. Zakin's point of view
regarding Muslims falling constitution
and also I want to know if it's against
chapter 5:45 may Allah make our dean
prevail over all other religions
the question posed is that today Muslims
and non-Muslims alike they follow the
constitution and we know that the
constitution is written by human beings
whether Muslims or non-Muslims and they
consider the constitution to be
something on the top and all the
countries they follow the constitution
even if it goes is the Sharia and and
the Quran clearly states in surah Ma 5
verse number 44 that you have to judge
by what Allah has commanded and anyone
who doesn't follow the commandment of
Allah and does not judge according to
the ruling of Allah subhanaa tala they
are the wrongdoers so what is my comment
on the constitution according to me the
glorious Quran is the future world
constitution it is a proclamation to
humanity it is the most positive book in
the world it is a fountain of mercy and
wisdom
It's a warning to the heless. It's a
guide to the ering. It's an assurance to
those in doubt. It's a hope to those in
despair and a solace to the suffering.
Now, I do agree with the questioner that
every country has a constitution. And if
you analyze the constitution of almost
all the non-Muslim countries,
they may not allow you to follow Sharia
completely.
There are a few exceptions to the rule
like India. I'll come to it later on. As
far as the Muslim countries are
concerned, many Muslim countries claim
not all, some they claim that they
follow Quran and Quran is the
constitution. But practically I don't
know of any country in the world which
follow Quran completely. Some may follow
a small percentage, some may follow a
larger percentage. And there are many
Muslim countries who claim to be
secular. They claim to be democratic
etc. Now let us first
deal with the non-Muslim countries.
Allah says in the glorious Quran in
surah Isa chapter 4 verse number 97 that
when the angel of death comes to take
the soul and he asks how were you in the
land and when the replies that we were
subjugated and we were persecuted so the
angel replies isn't the world of Allah
big enough for you to migrate so here
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala in surah Nisah
4:97 if you know Quran this was revealed
in Makkah when the majority of the
people are Makkah they were mushiks
giving them guidance for the Muslim to
hij and the verse continues that all
those is in the world big enough for you
vast enough for you to migrate and all
those who do not sow the Quran continues
they will be going to hell and the verse
continues verse number 98 of except
those who are weak women men and
children and who do not have the means
to migrate. So Allah says if you're
living amongst the kufur amongst the
non-Muslims, Allah tells you to migrate
except if you're weak amongst the men,
women and children, you cannot migrate.
Allah will forgive you. So the ruling is
you have to migrate. You cannot stay in
a country where majority are
non-Muslims. And the verse then
continues and verse number 100 says that
as for those who leave their home for
sake of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala and if
they die in a land away from their home
for sake of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
Allah will give them a felicity a great
reward they'll get cha and there are
various such verses so according to the
ruling of the Sharia a Muslim is
supposed to stay in a majority Muslim
countries there may be exceptions and
such exceptions One is India because
India earlier was ruled by Muslims for
about a thousand years. Later on the
Britishers came and they made partition
of the United India. They made Pakistan,
Bangladesh, India. About one/3 Muslims
went into Pakistan, one third to
Bangladesh, one third remain in India
approximately. If you know one/ird of
the Muslim population
lives in the Indian subcontinent. So the
Britishers came and divided and
unfortunately weakened the Muslim. But
one thing good mashallah that India is
one of the few non-Muslim countries in
the world which has a Muslim personal
law. That means every Muslim living in
India has as far as the personal law is
concerned whether it be inheritance
whether it be marriage etc. They are
allowed to follow the Sharia allowed to
follow Quran and say the criminal law is
is common. The most important is the
person-in-law. So India is one of the
few countries in the world which allows
a Muslim. Even though it's a majority
non-Muslim country, it was first ruled
by Muslims. We have a Muslim person in
law. So I wouldn't put India in this
category of non-Muslim countries that a
Muslim should migrate from because you
know the Indian Muslims they have about
210 million according to the government.
Actually the numbers may be much more
250 or 300 million where will they go?
So the ruling here I feel it doesn't
apply and I've given this answer in my
earlier and India was one of the best or
the best non-Muslim country to live
before Modi came before 2014
and Modi came and ruled and he won in
the first election then second election
2019 he won. So for 10 years he had
absolute majority you know. So because
of that he tried to change many things
but alhamdulillah in the recent election
that took place a couple of months
earlier in the results are declared in
June 2024 Modi didn't win with majority.
He came back with the coalition. So we
pray to Allah subhanana wa tala that the
situation of Muslims in India becomes
better. But even at that time of course
we find that if you lived in those
states which weren't controlled by BJP
and RSS like Kerala like Hyderabad like
West Bengal of course Muslim were
following very well they were living
very peacefully and it's mentioned in
the constitution of India that it's
every citizen of India can preach
propagate and practice his religion.
Later on when Modi came he tried to
interfere with the constitution is
trying but alhamdulillah now that he's
no longer in the absolute majority we
pray that completely the whole of India
goes back to normal but coming back to
the other non-Muslim countries whether
it be the western countries whether it
be USA European countries etc where
Muslims land majority so the ruling of
the Quran I told you so I'm not in favor
of Muslims living in non-Muslim
countries and basically coming to the
question the constitution
There are things in the constitution
like in India there is not a single
point in the constitution or a single
rule in the constitution that forces any
Muslim to do something which is haram or
prevents him from doing something which
is further but in most of the other
non-Muslim country of course there are
things that you may be doing haram or
you may be forced to do haram and one
common thing now in most of the western
country is that they are forcing LGBT
lesbian, uh, gay, bisexual, pansexual,
and plus and queer. They're forcing. Now
our children are being forced to learn
about sex education to know that okay,
there's no problem. If you have two
mothers, there no problem. If you have
two fathers, we are being forced. Now
this is haram. So if you live in a
non-Muslim country I do agree that many
things of the constitution people are
living in the western country they are
paying tax and from the tax money many
innocent Muslims are being killed with
that tax money America for example if
you pay tax money to America with that
tax money America is spending billions
of dollars and giving aid to Israel to
kill tens of thousands of Palestinian
and this is happening since decades in
many European country whether it be UK
UK whether it be France they are giving
aid to Israel to kill innocent Muslims
imagine with your tax money if you are a
citizen part of your money is going and
killing our Muslim brothers and sisters
and there are many things which either
it's impossible or whether it's very
difficult for Muslim to practice I know
I mean I've got many friends you know
many of my friends etc when we speak to
them onetoone most of them agree that
Dr. Zakir you are right it's not right
for Muslims but may be asked in public
they may not be that vocal yes there are
some who yet consider a western country
to be a very good home for them but the
percentage is small majority agree
that's the reason many of the dies that
I know of they want to migrate many want
to come to Malaysia and they say
Malaysia is one of the best countries
for a Muslim to live or the best of the
worst or best available Muslim country
to live and You can see my answer on
that. I've given that a couple of times
before. I don't want to repeat it. So as
far as following the constitution is
concerned in the Muslim countries as I
said that some Muslim countries claim
that Quran is a constitution. Of course
they will not force you to do something
which are haram. But the government may
do haram. I think there is no country
that I know of in the world where there
are no reba banks. Yes, I just heard
that in Afghanistan they want to close
reba banks. I don't know of any country
in the world whether Muslim or
non-Muslim which doesn't have ribba
banks. Now ribba is the 12th major sin
in Islam. Interest is the 12th major
sin. And a prophet said there are
various levels of ribba and the lowest
level is like doing zena with your
mother. Imagine such a major sin. Immadi
labels it as 12th major sin after the
the five pillars of that after shik and
murder and black magic and the four
pillars of salah zakat Ramdan Hajj then
obedience to your parents and take care
of the orphans etc. Then number 12 sin
is dealing with rabba taking or giving
rabba according to Mhammed Dhabi. So
unfortunately unfortunately even the
Muslim countries I don't know of any
country which is following Sharia
totally some are following to a better
extent some medium some very limited but
at least in the Muslim country people
will not force you to do something which
is haram. So living in a Muslim country
is much better than a non-Muslim
country. They may tell you options of
doing haram. They'll not force you to do
haram. They'll not prevent you for doing
something which is far. So I don't know
in any Muslim country where they will
prevent you certain things okay like you
know dawa is difficult you know many of
the Muslim countries they prevent you
from doing dawa but as a whole living in
a Muslim country is better now coming to
the question that if the constitution is
not based on the Quran and the hadith so
what should we follow the answer is very
clear whether living in a non-Muslim
country or a Muslim country if the
constitution of the
tells you to do something which is
against the Quran and say, no Muslim
should follow it because for us Allah
and his rasool is far superior to the
constitution of any country and if they
force you to do something haram you
should not do it or if they prevent you
to do something which is fur then you
should do it. So if the constitution of
the country contradicts with the Sharia
the Quran and say you should follow the
Quran and the say and not the
constitution. But if there are certain
things which are optional in Islam and
makes you compulsory by the constitution
then no problem in doing it or something
the constitution
prevents you from doing which is allowed
in Islam. Mouba optional no problem as
long as you do not break the rule of the
Sharia. So for us Muslims our
constitution is the Sharia the glorious
Quran and the say hadith. So we should
follow the constitution and agree with
the verse of the Quran of sur maida
chapter 5 verse number 45 we say that
those who do not judge by the ruling of
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala they will be
amongst the zalmoon they'll be amongst
the wrongdoers and we pray to Allah
subhanana wa tala that may he not make
us amongst the saloon and may he make us
stand for the truth for the h and may he
make us follow the Quran and say hadith
so that all the Muslims enter inshallah
Hope that answers the question.